[Music]
I cut my finger
everybody dance okay if you think it
looks stupid dance
[Music]
markiplier it mark markiplier mark
markiplier occupiers
Marcus markiplier mark mark mark
markiplier everybody my name is
markiplier and welcome no non dancin too
bad mark mark mark mark pirate
mark mark mark markiplier everybody my
name is markiplier and welcome
look at the floor there we go that's
right oh sorry chica okay okay all right
have enough of that Care Bear ready ever
been dancin everybody Hut hair by out of
breath hi how's it going welcome to the
fan gamestream which I've been promising
for quite some time I have indeed I've
been promising this for a while so hello
Oh crystal roses at graduation why now
why not because I felt like it um so in
this stream is what I'm gonna do what I
promise to do a long time ago which is
I'm going to play myself some fan games
and I'm gonna start off with a whopper
of a fan game that's supposedly like
three to four hours long so get ready
for a long stream because I'm gonna beat
this game because this is the first of a
trilogy so I'm out of breath from all
that dancing but hang on everybody hold
your horses hold on everybody I know I
know you're all at school I know I know
I know but watch anyway because it's
your flight or something yeah dance I
hope I hope those some of you guys that
were dancing in class just like in the
back row you know it's kind of like
bopping to the beat
okay so welcome to The Legend of
markiplier and I know it sounds a bit
pompous but this is the fan game that
came out in 2015 and I haven't played
until now because it's been so long
Christopher Chris arose bird says okay I
love you all watch it's okay but you
proud of me I'm proud of you just
because you're graduating doesn't mean
that you can't watch a little markiplier
which is a lesson to all of you out
there hey whatever you're doing there's
always time for markiplier so I am going
to play this game in just a few minutes
just so people have it in here and they
can see the beginning of it but thank
you all so much for joining me on this
early morning stream and I want to get
to this game because it was important
for me to play these fan games and it
always has been and always will be and I
just want to make sure that came across
in that you know I I fulfilled my
promise on this one because these fan
games are special to me I played a ton
of them I've got over playlists of them
with about 30 episodes in it some of
them up to an hour and over an hour long
so I spent a lot of time playing these
ones and this one might be the biggest
yet but this is only the first of three
and it's very highly rated too so I just
wanted to get it it's do play it see how
it goes see this adventure that they
have set up for me I've heard that the
second game is really really hard
sometimes so I'm wondering if this one
is hard too and I know I know I know I
know you guys are all at school that's
part of the reason why I kind of changed
my schedule bit fuchal stirrer says mark
is mark's biggest fan yeah just check
out my tumblr it's nothing but a
markiplier fan blog and the best
markiplier fan blog if you ask me in my
opinion and he any good selfie of me
i'll reblog it I don't care I've got no
shame ah anyway hello everybody we're
gonna get starting just like a minute
here countdown on your
markiplier markiplier yeah I woke up
early this morning and I was just like
man I really feel like I don't know I
just felt like I don't know you ever you
ever just wake up one of those mornings
and you just feel like you're not doing
enough I mean I get that a lot I get
that a lot but lately more than ever
I've been feeling that just because I
don't want to do more and I want to be
able to do more for guys I want to be
like push myself not just in terms of
like making more videos with making
better videos and higher quality and
figuring out like the better way to do
that and I think also it comes back
around to you know giving thanks and
giving back to the community that gives
back to me so much and I'm like among
all the things that you guys make for me
with the fan art and music and the games
like I gotta I like I I always see it
but I never really acknowledge it
publicly and I always feel like that's a
bit of a neglect for me so I want to
make sure that I play these games
because they are very important they're
like what you guys do for me is very
important to me and I always want to
make sure that's that's said so with
that being said I'm gonna get the game
going here let's see about this halusky
enough that means go up and listen to
that music thumping for about 25 minutes
treat oh hello ah to be me I always love
this part about the fan games I'm yeah
ah let me try to be 2015 me
[Music]
what a beautiful day not that much
different
also I cut my finger making breakfast
wait a minute ah where am I how do I get
here this isn't my house I need to
figure out what's going on here hmm
or do I owe who reads books out I do I
just read I just finished a book last
night I started reading Warhammer 40k
books these golden rods smell nice okay
I don't keep coltan [__] sticks to my
pen
this must be tiny box Tim's bed I love
my little biscuit I forgot to recorded
an episode of drunk minecraft last night
oops
ah this isn't my computer where's my
computer damn these limited sprite sets
oh this is adorable
I like I have the double stairs here
this makes sense what's that mysterious
sound could it be could it be Timothy oh
it could be hello oh hi mark
Jesus no my little biscuit what are you
doing oh you know just hopping around do
you know where we are tiny bucks Tim not
a clue maybe you can find some business
sounds like Mickey just but maybe you
can find someone who knows what's going
on let's see all right thanks bye mark
okay at least it's the same point I'm
gonna have to do that that voice for the
entire time fresh clean dishes glasses
stoves on why is anything for seems a
little dangerous to just have a bucket
of fish out in the open here alright bye
Tim I'm gonna go see what the hell's
going on whoa I should probably lay off
the alcohol yeah this gate was made in
2015 before a elf
crisis that made it so I couldn't drink
alcohol anymore bet you five bucks I'm
in a fan game again god dammit god
dammit why does he sound like Mickey I
don't know why something's like Mickey I
have no idea where I am or how I got
here
oh boy here we go oh wow its markiplier
I'm Sammy the world's biggest sanic the
Hedgehog though oh my god its movement
groups outs what the hell hi hi there
how are you how are you singing a dozen
different voices at once what do you
mean oh you know what never mind
anyway I probably should get going see
you around man okay then I'll just stay
in your house fine okay wait was there
something over in the locked class it
should probably investigate all right
Glenn who lost the door in their own
house I don't know people that don't
want strangers to come in oh boy here we
go
[Music]
I found the blacksmith too bad it seems
to be closed damn it
all right fine then oh who is this
imposing figure over here Oh must you
always be so negative Teddy's well I'm
sorry Alex but we can't have people
appearing all over the damn country and
no idea where they're coming from that
includes us well jeez that's a little
dramatic well if you do the kick-ass
youtuber markiplier which I could learn
through Superbook but unfortunately
judging by the people arriving in
constantly probably should have expected
you to arrive sooner or later nice to
meet you uh do I know you
fanboy we visit the same like rather
dramatic like music I feel like they're
gonna beat me up soon if I don't like
why are they nice to me this feels like
music that they should be horribly
horrible to me see
I am so Emmys a huge fan of yours
definitely something Alex it's a DS Ted
yes yeah whatever you say
ignore him she's Moody anyway you're one
of my idols mark always happy to meet a
fan but do you know where we are how did
I get here ah yes alright you're not
going to explain anything what don't
look at me for some reason a bunch of
youtubers
homes and sucked into whatever world
this is blah blah blah has it that the
king ruling miss Lam guards a portal
back to our world of course you need to
get them King first his return this land
is incredibly hostile deadly but if you
want to get back to where you belong you
need to get to the obsidian castle and
if you kick yeah lately new arrivals
have been heading out of the quests the
castle my friend Terry is here and I are
just about to leave ourselves do you
know how to fight with a sword of course
I do I've got a magic katana stick that
I can beat the [__] out of anybody that
doesn't come to a live dream I can do
that good then here's a gift for you
Merry Christmas I got a sword
I got a wordy sward thank you
thank you for this thank you here's
hoping we meet again take care of
yourself out there oh yeah you ready to
go turkeys ready as I'll ever be Alex
curves Eddie's Roger that let's move on
okay I don't know how wise this is I cut
my finger this morning making breakfast
he gave me a freaking sword I'm gonna
jump my head off well they seem like
nice guys guess I better go look for
this castle thing how hard can it be
well probably very hard if I had any
inclination of oh now that Ares guy said
to find the castle ah what could
possibly go it's Final Fantasy 7 alright
excuse me while I go gallivanting with
my freakin sword and then hopefully not
die a horrible death uh
as a final fantasy 7 it's like any final
fantasy overworld Oh corrupt youtuber
game stars that you okay alright then
whoa boo ski alright
hahaha loser right boom huh boo ski well
there we go then gets them looks
absolutely nothing oh he's cool I like
it I mean uh go to sunshine sure why not
oh hi well you how you doing there stea
damn it
free the hell are you are you a father
this is markiplier he's one of those big
youtubers oh well still what do you
Hughie want I don't know go back home
maybe but there's nothing here for you
markiplier you might as well go I've
been hiking back to where you came from
okay what if I go this way then you'll
have to pay the toll that'll be - um
good call what for for wasting our time
here
sign some paper you did it like that
there are so many sonic fans in this
ayah douche [__]
alright finally
he doesn't got anything father I see
begone peasant all right
and don't come back until you could pay
the fine you said it was a toll not a
fine a fine is for a punishment at all
is just to pass
all right fine then would be would you
want hi guys hello everybody we are
currently streaming markiplier fan games
and this is going to be a doozy what a
bunch of dicks
especially that soon eat you ok hello I
have a sword why won't you die already
that's pretty it's pretty the pretty
mean he's not gonna be ready tucked into
them full of [__] Bob you made it hey
Mark you got stuck here too yep so what
are you doing oh you know just standing
here can I get through not a feeling Oh
Oh Bob of course you would hmm
thank you was this some kind of
mysterious energy around this rock some
kind of secret these are a bunch of
strange rocks some kind of mysterious
energy around this rock coming out of it
I'm so giggly coz they're getting
distributed
I like repetition makes me laugh always
I probably shouldn't bother them they're
in a mating ritual all the way across a
river they must be powerful alrighty
then
oh no it's keep stuff again oh yeah oh
yeah how we you're not actually supposed
to hit me oh yeah okay there we go and
away we go
mark was victorious mark is now level 2
so am I gonna actually have to pay 200
gold unfortunately due to an eruption
you cannot proceed come back later
alright fine then good boy aren't you
others she's over there Lane
hello leave it looked like such a badass
dinosaur ah
what are you alright then you're not
gonna answer me that's a little read but
okay whatever okay so I think I know
what I need to do I need to farm up 200
gold which means I need to kill two more
of these guys and then I'll just go on
my way hoppity
easy easy because I just need to get one
more do I get anything for leveling up
status do I can I quit the arty put it
out put it on I never mind that I guess
I'm good
oh do I have a magic the pantsless
wanderer is that what is it the path the
pantsless wonder ah I like the pantsless
wanderer better that's a little more my
style
cuz I'm just wandering aimlessly in this
world hoping to find something oh look
it's another cave star black mark emo
emo mark why am i emo a my email right
now it's coming wait let me get emo for
you guys hey guys what's up its me a map
liar here ready ready to give 200 gold
listen meet you over there and his
father who apparently need 200 gold stay
there well you wait hearkening to fix
I've already done this guy's dead
literally dead lit in Italy ah
Oh lost 200 going oh I wasn't talking to
you okay hey what was that for you may
pass now subject we will meet again
alright okay bye see ya later
indeed we shall I got nothing against
Sonic very but that's funny
Jesus you dicks man alright then
oh hi mark this place leads to the
sunshine forest haha so happy would you
like to say yes I would yes I would Tim
yes I would uh mr. Markova says have you
seen tried the game I made markiplier
inner demons on gamejolt I have not but
I will check it out there's a ton a ton
of markiplier fan games on gamejolt and
i need to get through them eventually I
will get through them all but oh this is
gonna suck and this music is getting old
not really I'm I find it quite pleasant
does this rock have mysterious energy in
it does any of this have mysterious
energy in it so I'm guessing this is why
the game is long there are sick
roxrite ah a giant bee with some
curvalicious curves I don't know I don't
know I'm attracted to that be
[Music]
the bee stings hark why why am i
attracted that me that be maybe he's not
sexual in any way is it Oh
looking at that thorax I don't know why
what's wrong with me I had no idea
everything is wrong with me right
Jesus am I supposed to be able to beat
this thing I heard this game might be
hard but it boy didn't think it'd be
this hard time B come on just die
already good cop
I need a hill after this this is gonna
suck was I not supposed to be here yet
oh there we go geez I need a better
weapon mark with the 25 that was it for
all that I did there I got the same
exact amount of exp that I got for
beating up Kings star outside good God
all right fine then we're just gonna
deal with that that's gonna be a thing
that we're gonna be doing oh boy
everybody still okay with my email Ness
what is this hello a campfire the hell
am I supposed to do with this
would you like to light the bonfire
uh-huh
so we're playing Dark Souls I hate you
developer well no I'll actually like
Dark Souls
I love Dark Souls actually I actually
really liked blood-borne - I was playing
Dark Souls 3 and I did that thing that
I've done with games recently where I
just haven't finished them I I got
through like maybe 80% of the game and
then I just wasn't the UH man-eater plan
will he pull a person yeah that's what
I'd say at that all right well at least
one this one is taking normal amount
damage just fall over just fall over
maneater with your weird Magoo mouth
don't blow me but gently poison don't do
that
just don't do that look gross right fall
over
come on that was a so much damage don't
blow me with deadly poison I'm immune
all right there we go
please give me some more exp fifty there
we go that's better alrighty now we're
talking about something here okay
I also got a heal after it no I don't
actually because I'm gonna be leveling
up aren't I I see it's gonna be all
right hmm all right here we go again
flap yeah um Tyler Slade says can't wait
to see you live in Dallas Texas who Lisa
septic super flyer says it's that dark
applier I'm just in my chemo form
Rachael Clarke says hi I recently raised
eleven hundred for charity in the 24
hour live stream ah with my production
company sidetrack productions can we get
a shout out well there you go
congratulations for raising so much
money for charity really proud of you
that's awesome
uh wait oh wait hang on let's see here
wait cut damn it why is this not what
why is this broken
what is it broken that's goddamn broken
I don't know why hang on let me give
this thing here
I'll be right what I'm not going
anywhere but everybody hold on it's
broken why is it broken
hey guys one sitting here we go and
shabu Ski there we go okay got that blue
okay there we go okay uh Colin Andrew
says no that's not right either is it
now no it's not okay got it
sorry I just got to set up some windows
here because I'm not prepared for
anything uh or was it
there we go Colin Anders said you
mentioned Warhammer 40k and I just
couldn't help but ask if you have a
favorite army please don't say Eldar or
tau log well I can see that you're a
dirty heretic after all and you should
be purged by the fires of the Empire
puffy Emperor because it gross I don't
know I'm just getting into Warhammer
it's really interesting if you haven't
read any of the Warhammer 40k stuff it
is uh well it's a wild ride because it's
so grim dark and it's awesome and I love
that but it's just such a wild wild
assort wall kay all right then it's just
such a wild assortment of uh of
different things in
and once a when we get back to where I
was yeah it's such a wild assortment of
different uh different dark destinies
but it's really cool yeah
Oh Trevor Paskowitz I've seen the game
it's it's okay I've seen your spam I've
seen it yeah I've seen it
thank you yeah BLAP I need to heal
myself after this okay
all right am i gonna level up again or
do it
oh my god I'm poison to this roast right
lool alright there we go
wow wow wow man this is good this is
definitely gonna suck oh jeez okay let's
see uh lawless King says my a mark I
can't believe you're doing a livestream
on my birthday oh yeah boy I just want
to see if I can get a happy birthday
Ally
try not to rage too are today and stay
your mini self you're a big inspiration
I'm not a living mean but I I haven't
played a good rage game in a long time
thankfully for my blood pressure but so
you know I'm kind of I was thinking
about that last night - I haven't had a
chance to play it good rage game where's
the black specks why do I need to shout
that in every little town that I go into
this ridiculous we need to get out of
here okay alright then locks
mysteriously and again the frickin music
people must think I really like that
music no no I don't it's gotten a bit
old this place looks awfully familiar
uh I'm still poisoned oh my god how do I
get rid of that do I have an item that
can get rid of that nice it's a potion
hello there what can I get for you I
already have a wood sword
shield yeah I can do that and a feather
hats I don't know what the other guy was
selling but maybe it was the same thing
hopefully because I just blew all of my
money ah antidote that's what I need I'm
just enough money for that thank
goodness because that was gonna suck and
also I wasn't gonna be able to see
anything for the wall I'm why do I want
to crawl into the forge there that just
seems like a stupid idea
alright let's see happy birthday to
everybody that's birthday it is why is
this a Dino town Tim Tim Tim Tim I
didn't mean to walk on you oh hi mark
would you like to save the game sure
sure Tim yes I would
bye mark locked so much for a free stay
well I have no money so there's no point
in me even being here so I'm just gonna
go on my way let's see hello why are you
blocking Ben yamimash MOC I thought I
heard your shout we need to get out of
here what are we supposed to do mark
I don't know how the book man my British
accent has died recently
we are gonna journey to the castle and
free the land let's go
what yamimash has joined her team all
right where are we going now I don't
know how we're gonna free the land we're
back in the map world oh it's the castle
okay
oh no this is the forest temple well
this isn't creepy at all let's just be
careful mark but of course of course I
will of course I will
ah yes oh oh hi I didn't think we'd meet
again this soon who are they
dicks dick 1 and dick
well if it isn't suck-up liar as his
friend yamimash that's right
yucky bash really yo I told you not to
come this way and now you go come on
Cindy cheer let's beat him up right
behind your father okay son let's beat
up this random youtuber that we ran into
because of no other reason than other
than we hate them all right fine then
see how it goes
[Music]
blam I guess we're just gonna go for the
know the big guy is that Christian is
that if it that's supposed to be oh I
didn't even realize that that is so
Christian Right and wind Sonny's you
blam
thank you yeah alrighty then Wow Rihan
okay back we're good
okay so I'm just gonna keep going after
Sinise you because maybe if he Chris
channel becomes so distraught after
Sunita dies right now why he make you
[__] but wins and eat you BLAP yeah
oh no he's not that all right thank you
now we're just gonna blast on you
[Music]
Oh destiny Brunel says just wanted to
pop in and say hi before I start work
hope your week is going well it is going
well it's off to a wonderful start I'm
really happy with the way things are
going this week because I've got a lot
of cool things in store and nothing I'm
not making any promises or anything but
I'm just like I'm really excited about
this week in the future and what we got
going on and also like I feel better
just because like I've actually been
working out again I'm an eating
healthier and everything's been going
good and also my hair is more emo my
crops are thriving my acne is gone my
skin is clear my children are spawned
you know it's great my life is great
everything is wonderful in my world yeah
see oh and happy Mother's Day everyone
Connor Hunt Preston said heard you like
World War Craft
what do you thoughts and lead to
honestly I have not had the chance to
play Legion because this is the first
expansion that I just have not played
Norden airily even if I don't really
like play the experiences fully I
usually level up to the next level and
then go as far as I can but for this one
I just I didn't play it and it's weird
like cuz normally I always do but for
this one I just I don't know I don't
know what it was I just didn't do it I
don't know why I just didn't do it so
unfortunately that was that way uh Eric
Goethe three one to four said hey Mark
just want to get a shout-out from you I
know Mother's Day was yesterday but
happy about Thursday to your mom I love
watching your videos that helps me out a
lot
oh thank you so much and I know my mom's
would appreciate that I I wish I could
have been there you know back home for
my mom because my mom facetimed me uh
from oh man what is going on both of us
would bolt down here this guy's a little
tough and I don't know why he's stunned
but I need him for I think he can cure
my oh oh oh good thing I healed
Bevin's can you yak here there we go
sure buddy booty okay and blue don't hit
me too hard there okay good all right
we're gonna we're gonna do that and then
we're gonna raise
now I try wind again I don't have a good
do anything huh no damage why now
whatever it's sir Moodle Joe says wow
you're up early mark what's up with that
this makes me very mad why does it make
you mad you're the one who fought us
you're the [__] in its equation right
blue huh blue uh-oh
blue blue man because we can't win this
guy he's gonna take a long time to be
able to die Oh what the hell is that I
thought there was something happening
there all right come on Christian just
fall over come on come on fall over
[Music]
this cockpit stood up Yoshi princesses
thank you for being so nice and awesome
also if you don't mind because I don't
want to bother you could you please give
me a shout-out to my boyfriend Mario
well hello Mario thanks so much for
being here and you got a lucky person
looking out for you stop it why would
you say stop it you're the one fighting
me Christian you're the one fighting me
you're fighting me I have no idea what
you are on poison get why fine you win
for now wait what do you mean I win for
now
I don't women are you just [__] hit
me one runaway teased a douchebag Oh
[Music]
any day now you can fall over a collide
lawsuit hey Mark
my name's reading me and my sister are
huge fans of yours you have no idea how
much she helped us out well thank you so
much for watching
really appreciate as soon as I deal with
Christian here we're gonna be towards
antigens also I just noticed I just
noticed he had like creepy shadowy
tendrils crawling out from oh there we
go that's more like it
full potion oh my god oh yes oh wow
yeah yeah okay all right then holy [__]
that's a lot of stuff oh it punched bash
how you big fat jerks you look at us
maybe you should look in the mirror
buddy
oh come on father let's go there's no
way these users can beat that guardian
alright sure okay okay we will meet
again alright bye and next time you're
gonna die what then you're the big jerk
well then you're a jerk well you're the
jerk in this equation you are the jerk
you know I really hate those guys I
don't even know them before today I
didn't even know them before 30 minutes
ago and I hate them
the kind of jerks aren't they onward
okay let's do this skadoosh kee ghanoush
have you guys seen the billboards videos
the history of the world if you haven't
you should it's amazing he made history
in Japan and then they just did too like
instead of like making it sequentially
just go like I bad just do the whole
[__] world it's great eerie
monotonous violin sounds too spoopy for
me
poopy I'm glad you're amused what's
wrong am I afraid of the dark we have no
idea what's in here this is a home we'll
remember
don't it's gonna get worse from here if
you think this is bad it's as good it's
gonna get worse
oh yeah alrighty then
okay whatever you say ooh what is that
can I say before I talk to this guy
hello you look ugly but not as ugly as
your mama it's more Bob's thing than
mine it's it see hey there gorgeous you
look scary Oh mark I don't think
touching this thing is a good idea
you're right Yami can I regret I great
doll I didn't want to do that I wasn't
ready for it I didn't say oh no it's
gotta be okay I'm gonna do quick move on
me I guess you're gonna do wind on the
giant because [__] that be oh yeah oh
[Music]
[Applause]
sorry do you like my remix event looking
friggin think that should finish all
with oh wait that hit quite that hit
there buddy boo
alright so now we just gotta take care
of this guy and I gotta get I should
have I believe yamimash has the ability
to cure that so I'm just gonna wall up
on them
let's see cure keep poison and now we're
just gonna wham bam until we can get
there uh Top Gun production says hey
mark love your videos I was wondering if
you're planning on going back and
getting the true secret ending in one
shot yes I do I know about it I will do
it very soon I just haven't had the time
to eat and dedicated to that uh Ethan
Galloway who says I'm trying to get a
girlfriend any tips um just be yourself
focus on yourself first more than trying
to get a girlfriend I mean trying to get
a girlfriend is a weird goal you should
try to make connections with people
first and then you know whoa oh hi come
on with denimm talking about how to get
a girlfriend Marga Blair's dating advice
over here don't worry about I know what
I'm doing
[Music]
laughs me laughs me real good
oh I missed something here hang on one
second I know there's an any blood what
are you talking about also like the
musical remixers of all my screams look
I you say I used to promo those in like
all the endings of every video and then
I just started to use the same one organ
I always felt bad about that okay all
right I didn't always feel bad about
that I forgot about that
I want us bring John one there's more
things like that but you know it's just
like it gets in the way yeah you focus
on too many other things and kind of
forget like like what what's really cool
and like this sort of stuff is what's
really come talking to you guys and let
me you guys experiences with me is also
like a really good again black important
both of us like you douche we got to
cure that because that's gonna get us
down oh man this guy takes no damage we
are going to have a rough time here
especially considering the only person
that can actually do the magic stuff is
the one who's preoccupied with curing
everybody so if that guy just constantly
does up
[Applause]
his things over and over again the words
got to be phoned because we're not gonna
be able to do anything what if I can
keep wailing on him that we're actually
gonna get there all right see this is
he'll again again
let's see Oh Meg Smith hi Marc I'm
pregnant and hormonal watching you is
making me smile and you hope you have an
amazing week lots of love for me and my
partner Jack from the UK well best of
luck to you with that I've never been
pregnant myself so I don't know if any
advice but dating advice I have no idea
what I'm talking about and I'm gonna
shut up before I had just good luck all
right thank you I've been god dammit
stop blowing us with poison you know
what we're just gonna be able to poison
whale on this guy because I'll just heal
because I don't know how much poison
it's gonna take but at least he won't be
continually poisoning us and I know
we'll be able to will be able to heal up
just about as fast simply as we can take
the for you
see
Balto husky says hey mark my name is
Tran I love your videos for these are an
inspiration to me uh so I will be seeing
you at your Dallas stop oh thank you so
much and thank you for coming with us on
the tour it's gonna be awesome
also I just want to mention the tickets
are pretty much all so that I believe
that just about everything is sold out
the only thing I think has tickets left
is Dallas I'm not sure I think it might
have some tickets left but if you wanted
to come to the tour this is just the
first leg so even though these are all
sold out or they're close to sold out
check them there should be a link down
the description below but check them out
if they are then there will be more
shows this fall and winter of the for
now that's all we got and then the show
is going to be coming to you and this
guy needs to die because he just keeps
poisonous Jesus alright um you're gonna
run out of magic eventually if we can't
get this guy down flap just fall over
already
Oh can't out seal this freaking thing
let's see um let's see ah
Civil War says hey mark long time you
were just here to let you know when you
go to bed millions of people watch you
ah that's a comforting plot
thank you and I appreciate the winky
face associated with that one makes me
feel real good about the fact that
people watch me when I sleep
Oh finally get defeated even he was like
oh people watch you in your sleep Oh
fade off into the distance yeah all
right full potion was found dispel herb
was found mark his level nine thunder
was learned oh yeah should be that's
gonna get didn't save do easy ah sure
there's something in here oh we probably
shouldn't you know what I'm just gonna
not listen to you at all and reach into
everything that I can find and then just
stick my head really mork yeah I know
all right so you need to cure thyself
and heal thyself the timid Brit ah yes
the timid Brit ooh what is this Oh Oh
hand me that pipe or book this place
leaves on searching for Zod okay boy
goodbye dough boy good boy all right
okay moving on then well that wasn't so
bad at all I think I can finish this
game then ah okay I think I got this on
lock oh hello
be careful these monsters are tough yeah
I bet they are have you seen my muscles
they're pretty
bulgy they're pretty bloated if you a
scream oh come on why do I have to
freeze my butt off now this game rocks
it doesn't suck don't be sore in your
sorry fella
it's so cold Oh goddamn no templates go
to somewhere war rubber please hurry
mark look at the don't die on me Kim
please right [__] you [__] you [__] you
[__] you
alright skedaddling off into the this oh
so cold I got a bad feeling about this
you're not the only one walk all right
I'm sorry I'm so sorry to everyone
watching in the UK right now uh who do
we have now
oh now you're not as sexy yeah I thought
maybe for a second Ruth under it yes
please thunder and wind baby
caboose key what is key - more powerful
mine why is this more power I mean I'm
not really like of the type to just be
like Oh his is bigger than mine why I
feel bad about no I'm like it's just
like why is this more powerful than mine
I'm not saying like I I thought I used
my thunder real good there I thought I
used it like a skillfully oh hi look at
their smiling faces
haha we're gonna get ya
my life took no damage I was lightning
just no worker did it resist just as I
miss doesn't mean you need to punish me
okay I guess they're immune to thunder
and they aren't that just twice why is
it immune to mine and not is I don't
want to say that my mine's not as good
but I mean I think it is but you know
maybe it might should be just as good as
his like I just feel like if his hits
mine should hit why do I get rejected
because of my small slightly my average
thunder why will imma try one more time
but hopefully no bogus fist wicket at
second you know life at the dice that
get donut yeah then you just make do
with what you got okay all right then I
guess oh and he levelled up good great
that's cool too I guess he leveled up I
didn't level up but whatever ask who I
don't feel bitter know what I'm saying
why does he have an even thousand elf
y'see that's cool I wish I had an even
number for else I can just cut by ninety
seven which is just as cool almost a
school 777 if I was a minion or Lord oh
hi I can't hit you that's fine though
fix ships it's packed and I've been 44
damaged you know it's almost as much as
500 I always [__] I feel like I'm an
active participant in this fight here I
feel like this is just as much on me as
it is on him
anyway Oh Bailey crew says hello mark
from Australia hope you have a good day
man Jessica Smith says hey Mark just
wanted to stop in and say thanks for
being such a big inspiration I
appreciate everything you do
oh you have a great day too all right
I'm Jason Pierce's thank you so much for
being Hugh keep doing what you're doing
and know that you've helped many people
through many things including myself you
save many people you're the real MVP
why does yamimash do 200 damage and just
a normal attack I feel like maybe I
should do a lot of damage on your old
dad I'm paralyzed okay I'll just sit
here doing nothing
great all right cool we did a lot here I
feel like we did a lot with me included
I feel like I helped do a lot of this I
feel like I helped oh hey how's it going
this will hit you right this will hit
you blam 300 deaths good number this
that's a better number all right then
whatever you say time it's alright it's
good
Thomas Willie says hello watching you
whilst painting a chaos of Chosen chaos
Murray miniature also Wanda thank you
for cheering me up today you give this
diss less dyslexic novelist hope also
dragons dragons dragons dragons okay all
right then lyrical miracle nine six oh
eight says hi mark my name is Luke I'm
from England in the UK I've been a fan
of yours for about a year and a half
love you lots so have an awesome day all
thank you so much and I apologize for my
horrible horrible British accent
horrible truly god-awful terrible the
worst though the world has ever seen
all right how's it gonna spam attacks
here let see us Wibbly hey Mark huge
tram forever I was wondering if you had
some advice for a completely new let's
player and relatively new cover song
here
I love making people happy and you are a
master of that I wonder if you could
find a way to blend the two you know
what I mean because being a cover singer
is really cool I mean being a let's
player is fine too but it's hard because
there's a lot of competition but I would
never tell people not to do it I mean I
would warn people against it that there
is a lot of competition in it but at the
same time if you're a new let's player
like always try to find a new way to eat
something fresh something like unique to
you and something that you enjoy find
find that one thing and then keep going
why do they keep hitting me
why do they keep hitting me they're not
they're not hitting yamimash they're
hanging mean straight of me why are they
on I just feel like I'm being singled
out here for my average thunder I mean
yamimash is grandiose wind is impressive
and all but I feel like I'm just as just
as equal part of it if you do anyway
I'll just carry on I think I went the
wrong way so I gotta make a loop bow
Frek well if I wanted a farm exp here I
go Kaleigh Laverty says my boyfriend
hunter and his sister Hayden wants you
religiously I pretty much fall asleep
and wake up to do videos every day so
thanks for your amazing videos let's see
uh Taylor cook scent-marking we used to
check out befores it's cute multiplayer
game I've enjoyed so far thank you for
spreading to your and laughs every day
well thank you so much ray dable says hi
mark just wanted to tell you that you're
an awesome and that you helped me
through the hard time in my life past
that I hope you have a great day
well thank you so much I'm having a
really good day this is like there's
like the best way that I could possibly
hope to start my day just by playing you
like these fan games it's just really
really cool I should be hitting this guy
with magic because he is he is walloping
us there you go take some of that home
with you ah
Satan says thank you mark so much for
allowing people to donate to wonderful
organizations to help out many people
during these I'm especially pleasantly
surprised to see you playing fair games
again me too
thank you meme Satan I'm actually really
happy to be back into the fingers as
Melanie I just feel like you know I feel
like it's been too long
you know it's one of those things where
you knew that you should be doing it and
yet you keep putting off because you
don't have time and it's like hey what
kind of excuse is that there's no excuse
for that you just gotta you got it you
got to do it and you got to make time
for these things because these are the
important things and these are the
things Brown Rock psycho says hi marker
you got to be playing lots of fan games
I told you about mine five days of
markiplier at PAX and it's my dream for
you to play it if so I can only laugh at
your attempt at a British accent
thanks for everything that's right yeah
I remember that then I I do remember
that and that's actually I think when I
first said I know that's true
to you it was the first time I ever said
I should probably do live streams of fan
games and now I'm doing it so high all
the way from Beck's oh this is come full
circle thank you so much that's
delightful
oh and then wacky tomato says hey Martin
wanted to tell you that you're my
favorite youtuber can you say hi to
Reena
I love you cuz you're weird like me I'm
not weird limited IDI pose is that
limited erectile-dysfunction pals
because I'm not so sure about that I'm
not 100% sure about that that's a little
Oh Cameron Kurt says Marxist came here
to have a good time but he's feeling so
attacked right now you are my
inspiration thank you oh thank you
let's see um haneul Dara Singh says I
spent all my money on making daily
content because I believe presentation
is 50% of everything you shed light at
the end of the tunnel so thanks Wow
I mean I'm not sure what you're making
but whatever it is I really do hope it
works out for you I'm assuming it's
something physical that's gonna be
costing you a lot of money like that but
just good luck to you I mean whatever
you're creating if it's fulfills you
like you'll find a way like that's what
happens when you know you're struggling
and a lot of people think that just
because I have success now means that
I've always had success and that's not
true to any extended cat which way my
supposed to go here I'm lost in a maze
and but I was in the beginning I used to
struggle a lot you know not none terms
of making videos but in terms of like
you know living and having money and
being able to do that so we're stuff
like if we don't hang out here soon
we're gonna freeze to death yeah oh I
only have 45 seconds left all right I
don't need to heal just yet loudly hope
I don't get stuck in the wrong way oh
boy I have a funny feeling I'm gonna
freeze to death and I don't know what's
gonna happen if I freeze death because I
need to flee okay we just got to go we
got to go because it go we don't have
time for anything else oh my god don't
kill me if you kill me with this
[__] I will be very pissed because I
will if I have to go all the way back to
tiny box Tim I am going to be very
pissed because that is a long stop it
you do not do this not now not now I do
not want to go
back all the way double rainbow oh no no
no no no no no no no no no sorry for
blowing out your eardrums everybody
god damn it okay hi now yes you can
attack me uh man gaging says hey mark
love the happy moody bringing your
videos then just make my day and by the
way watch out a mimic bind you I'm gonna
die a question mark let's see ah hey
Mark hjs says mark how do you deal with
all these messages that you are the
savior hero etc I think that's a lot of
pressure to put on one shoulder um what
I realized is it's a lot of pressure to
have in it so it's a lot of things to
think about but at the at the end of the
day I just have to keep doing what I've
been doing with it in mind
I don't have to be this hero you know I
don't have to act like a hero I mean
large I don't have to act like I am
literally saving their lives every day
even though people will say that but
when people say that I'm just honored
and I'm motivated more to do what I do
already I'm motivated to keep going
motivated to push myself on making
videos and just being here and doing
more stuff with you guys
to communicate with you guys and being
able to be here like with you and if you
could stop silencing me I'm not even
doing that I feel very attacked right
now all right Gwen key far greetings
from Germany you are by far my favorite
youtuber I hope that you will come to
Germany err Fishbach I will soon even
though I haven't been keeping up with
the German I've actually switched to
Korean I've been taking lessons from my
mom and that's awesome
Oh for the love of enough ice caves
already Jesus Christ
um are you talking to Mike the game
developer okay then
alright whatever you say walk all right
where we going here don't get me lost
cuz Ivan ahahahahaha
you know developer if you knew this was
such Ditka tree why'd you do it in the
first place
alright come on come on bring it on at
least it gives me plenty of time to read
you guys's comments so um the third
Saint says mark er the best never lose
your drive in sincerity the world needs
more positivity like yours right now
huge fan thank you so much Hayley dot
exe gaming says hi listening to you
while doing schoolwork Katy closet says
mark can you show us chica uh oh
chicas napping in the corner you know I
don't
bother too much thank you so much though
[Music]
average Jay says thanks for being you
and I thought those dragons were called
ball sacks well I think that's just you
being a little immature but that's okay
because that's the kind of immaturity
I like all right if they can just fall
over and die that'd be great - any day
now also I'm paralyzed I'm just gonna do
a whole lot of nothing immediate
resilence
still not gonna move I'm just gonna be
here reading [__] well yummy does all
the work for me that's that's how I do
please feel that good all right moving
on
he's not more help than okay that's just
annoying you know what I'm not gonna
deal with that you just I'm gonna
skedaddle off and there we go
gosh mark limited Edie means limited
edition I don't think that's what that
means I'm pretty sure that was a limited
erectile dysfunction oh god it's a dead
end
oh this is a non-gang this is a nut yang
this is annoying and I'm hitting these
guys with a wooden sword you think that
I would have smart it up and getting
like one of these ice into a sword shape
and this started stabbing people in
their kidneys
eventually I've got to get it somehow
some way is just gonna happen someday
someday please please be a way out don't
be a dead end don't be a dead end
oh don't be a dead end don't be oh it's
not okay it's not okay thank you still
gonna run away because screw you guys
I've got so much gold and not enough
money with which to do anything for this
oh it's a dead end
oh no it's not a dead end it's almost a
dead end but it's not a dead end
alright delayed a day liddie liddie
up here but diddly diddly do should this
better not just go back into the ice
cave frozen past does that mean that
it's gonna take me to where I need to go
namely the ice temple if that is what
this is and then I'm gonna be able to
get out of here maybe why is it such a
maze why why is it such a maze but why
though but why okay alright then good
bye good bye good bye good bye Freddy
Freddy move please
[Music]
he telling me he telling me
hmmm there's multiple there's multiple
caves here I'm just gonna I'm just gonna
go this one on the other side just to
see if I can't and this would be better
with a run function that'd be good let's
see no mm-hmm
levy Hammond said why they up the day up
the monster Chan's in this one didn't I
Hey
oh is that a campfire why but why though
your team has been fully restored but
they already were though I think he
anyway all right so there's another cave
over here that I can go through but hey
whatever let's see uh invisible Emily
said hey Mark my grandpa started
dialysis today thank you for making me
smile today well good luck to your
grandpa I really hope that it goes well
for him that is a rough way to go Tyler
has told me about when he went through
dialysis for his kidney transplant that
was a new doin ordeal indeed let's see
Chloe Joan says hey Mark what fan games
are you playing the game well this is
the legend of markiplier which is a long
spanning trilogy actually it's the first
part of the trilogy and I'm only on the
second temple of this entire endeavor
and I'm gonna blast through this whole
game in this one sitting so buckle ye up
it's about to get
dang I don't know if it's about to get
dang that's probably not the right word
for it
hopefully they sent me where I needed to
go please can you stop with the
interruptions thank you I need a better
weapon and fast all right this looks
good the mysterion that means we're
gonna have a temple ride home Oh Makka
Moo does not deploy say hello Oh Tundra
City yes yes please I need oh yes please
thank you please give me a weapon and
not yamimash all right iron mace but
slow
I'll take the sword ice shield that
seems important I have gold for two imma
take that and I'll take the leather shoe
I didn't equip the other stuff did I uh
and he has an iron mace is that why he
was doing the better than me probably
I'll buy another one of those but only
just because alright let's see if
there's any items over here that
see doodlee doodlee do I'm gonna get
more antidotes because that's easier
than
Athar for man
dispeller party a blows I don't need
that
alright let's carry on see what kind of
bad boy these guys are gonna throw at me
also if I get another party member
that'd be nice
hello this weather is ridiculous I came
from Vegas I never seen snow before you
go radical soda
hey it's radical soda why did you bring
me here what do you mean wasn't me
not this time then who did I don't know
but it wasn't me this time hmm
radical soda is the guy who made another
markiplier fan game I can't remember
what it was right now oh this is gonna
stop there oh woops sorry excuse me
a little bit of a gas all these
standardized places go to show a lack of
creating do it for the permits would you
like to rent a room only fifty gold no
no I need that tiny box Tim is right
there hi mark
alright whoops bye mark well didn't mean
to save over that one but I guess it
doesn't matter alright so we should have
what we need and if we meet someone else
up here it's gonna be good thing the
shop sale
I should equip them because I haven't
done that okay iron sword leather shield
chain Queen
and that's all she wrote for that you
get nothing you get nothing because
apparently you're a wither Wizard of
some sort
hello mead-hall okay hey dad let me
drink daddy's pupil oh yeah good okay
kid drink up that's a good message this
game should be saying walk'n'shoot
[__] god I could popular I could sure
use another one that's Jack alright hi
mark glad you could share would you like
something to drink
hey Jack how's going hey we should go in
better if I could give perhaps talk to
that lizard thing at the ball anyway
back to more drink
yep that's the thing - that's the best I
can do waiter
give me one over here just punch me
right in the face please it's all I want
that's all
oh all I want make that too much it's
right in his face
all right fine then it's okay keep
carrying on who are you again
yeah that's what I asked myself every
day how the bloody hell did you get here
oh well I guess it could be much worse
how stabbing needles in the eyes is not
gonna be much worse her he/she/it
I don't even know okay keep him got mine
I ain't going anywhere
well that's sad bartender give me
another stop shouting
very good I see that oh why are they
guarding my exit hi mark
glad to see you're still alive and
kicking Mark's here hmm good to see you
my friend I'm not your friend buddy we
met once how does that make me your
friend house you guys quest coming along
hey we're making some progress as I see
so having you is that the leap key
indubitably
I see so I take it you didn't have much
problems with the forest garden no not
really
who's these two stupid guys a big chubby
one in his Pikachu sonic crossbreed they
were guarding the temple oh great
they're here
who are Christian and his pal Sonny chew
Tereus and I had a nasty running while
back I would advise you to avoid them at
all costs good idea um will you go up
again Oh sir Aries turn
Tereus sir Aries Terriers how that
rhymes not the way I say it this is my
good friend yamimash yamimash the sir
Aries and his friend tereus they're
doing the same thing we are nice to meet
you
plays the pleasure's all know Alex huh I
mean sir Aries don't you have something
to give our friend
what oh that's right here you two go a
little gift we've seen the temple slab
[Music]
listen Elba you get to the Frost
guardian okay speaking of which we
should probably get going right a lot
all right arias let's move I bid you
adieu we'll be seeing you now that
rhymes the other one didn't rhyme okay
thank you for that I appreciate your
candor can I get a drink I'm very busy
can you shut up then can I go look at
tripping from this guy steal your drink
kid you shouldn't be drinking anyway so
I'm thinking maybe there's good some of
them fun how about me is it me can I
have fun yet can I have fun please I
want funny guy why I would like some fun
what is that little glimmer ah see [__]
I don't know some kind of Temple tablet
that's the key to unlock the floors
temple Oh words over my way back good to
go in sword when I found it all locked
apart needed something special to open
it well now that you have it I'm coming
with you top of the mornin do you
let's give Morse I told you it was gonna
get worse
why take a lot worse let us be going
alright then okay here we go
hike alright kind of abilities do you
have sexy Irish men has Saints steals
holy damage up an Irish Saint just like
an Irish priest
how cliche can you get alright so I
guess we're all good here
so I need to go to the temple which is
where I'm gonna and prepare for the
prepare for these uh these uh voices to
get all kinds of blended up because
accents are not my forte they are just
not not even remotely a little bit not
even kind of a tiny bit not even a
little tiny doodle of a doodle bit yep
no be Dobby alright let's see Oh Lexi
Brown says hi mark my little bro Dane is
such a big fan of your finesse series
obsessed is an understatement he would
lose his head if he heard you say hi
damn so hi Dame how's it going can I go
in here temple slab remove
so screw and in we go
hello anybody here anybody at all ah a
gaudy and I see hello baby you're not
gonna follow me everywhere are you
what is she sitting on I don't know Oh
have an eye on you gargoyles I'm not
gonna [__] you jigs creepy
what is she sitting on all right exactly
the same this time Oh Cassie too lazy so
this is the frost guardian Shea wait
here unfortunately to get the key I
think that's what we didn't do so touch
are you guys ready for Freddy
I'm gonna call you Freddy I'm not gonna
call him Freddy I'm not gonna do that
that's not what I'm gonna do Friday wake
up fine then there we go all right good
good good great
yeah all right let's do this I'm gonna
do my best moves on you bad boys we're
gonna we're gonna just focus on one yep
that's what blam
yeah blam
oh those so much damage I know they can
heal themselves and I got the focus of
mine this what amazing thing that's
happening that is so much damage okay
that's not as much damage but I'm
figuring that that guy has a lot of
armor on him okay all right then
hey this might be a lot easier than I
thought all right let's try this boy mo
oh I can actually damage him oh it's a
beautiful haha
I need more damage then you'll be mashed
now okay so uh Shane Grant says hey Marc
you're my number one subscription on
YouTube my favorite series of yours are
drunk minecraft and subnautica a locker
sure would be cool okay I'll try to
remember Shane gran but I don't know if
I'll be able to but I will do my best
blammo blameable mo uh really answers
just want faith is thank you for keeping
my sister smiling rough year so far well
I don't know what's been going on but I
wish you the best of luck in the rest of
the year and hopefully it gets better
for you Barry
see Andrea Molossia said thank you for
being a friend in my life I see Melissa
Mitchell says hey Mark you picked a good
day to go to Hindi nd pride is on the
same day and it's literally one Street
over from the venue so my best friend
and I will be going to that been to the
ATM show Wow yamimash took a wall of
there how about you uh kill yourself
there lam kabuki ok evade it that's also
a thing you can do
skinny ski ice to losing blood what is
going on here I love these remixes if
there's more remixes let me know I want
to see them like all the time wow wow
wow why you're an ice Guardian why can
you why am I still silent I've been
silenced forever let's see oh he's dead
Oh looking over a chat I was looking at
the chat metals and blammo
ok alright then Oh mark is now level one
st. was learned I learned Saint too well
now I have two attacks what's that's
gonna do I guess ones holy ones
lightning so that's good too close that
wasn't even close at all I got the frost
key for how [__] this whole place
was that was a lot easier all right but
that's good so we got two of six down
hell yeah oh alright hi-hi freezin it's
so cold I'm sorry Tim I didn't mean it
that way
please carry more voice please pray
please
all right I hurried hey Bob you gonna
join us this time
let's see you know after some thought I
decided that you need me to help you in
this questioners uh-huh sure do Bob
excellent
let's go mom is joining yeah ray leaves
that leaves way down in the lurch I
think I don't even know we can do that
the seductive Joker oh if there ever was
Oh Oh pumpkin - a lot the rock grew up -
[__] oh I'm such a child aren't I -
rainy peak yes old whoa whoa oh this is
gonna be a mess I really hate this game
look if you just watch him so much
playing in the rain is fun apparently it
is apparently as wine here goes nothing
I'm not controlling that am I
why's is so slow so tell me who's going
to be that slow the whole time okay
there we go
oh wow all right
the noetic gypsy says hi mark I'm
cosplaying as Lilith from Borderlands at
the detroit comic-con this Friday
you should come say hi and check it out
I am not anywhere close to Detroit what
do you think I am
poison bat poison bat boys oh come on
tickle you gosh darn dick hole I got a
heel yamimash here are you Windham you
bless them you blast all of them to hell
ow
boom well nope no damage there that
didn't work bubble ski that worked
apparently
how about Thunder with that work how
about that how about wind
BAM our key stop poisoning everybody
this is good view sucks blood now boom
it'll grow stop grupos kill I need to
heal jack wham bam blam
but dambha this guy's talking alright uh
wacky tomato says hey mark me again my
sister Lin Jie is a huge fan of you and
would die to hear you say hi to her
she's nine and do say something
inspirational well I don't know if I'm
pronouncing your name correctly but
thank you so much for watching
Stan's
every day is enough
other than just thank you so much for
watching and stay true to yourself and
that's it hi let's cure everybody up
let's heal everybody up because
apparently
we're all gonna be a little bit dancer
this is like this is rough there's rough
you know what I think I'm just gonna
cleave there's gonna be those bats again
because they're just a son of a [__] oh
come on no don't listen dog paws and may
all right there we go they don't give it
up a little warned to keep doing that
brown eyed psychosis can we have fangame
Mondays I love watching these games so
much keep being awesome Marcus buckle
I'll do my best
thank you so much man if I have to trot
through the sand I'm gonna just give up
because this is this is where God are
you oh I can oh I can press shift to run
that is a thing I can do come I always
bet if I I can sprint now there was a
cave-in no getting through wait you
[__]
I've been able to sprint this whole time
why didn't know that I didn't know that
at all
god damn it get away yeah I mean this is
a different canoeing not sprinting and
sprinting so it's not
that much dis you bunch of [__]
developer with the sandblasting stupid
piece of Garbo you can take this shove
it up but somebody poisons fats oh come
on oh boy oh God
all right Lexi Reece says hey Mark
thanks for videos when I can turn to
when I'm desperate for a spot when I'm
in desperate need for a smile Oh an
assassin that is mine
are you the butt stabber I don't think
soon today we're gonna blast the Garbo
out of you
um oh here they go uh by the way how
many weird looks do you get while
filming markiplier TV uh a few we had a
few run-ins with people they were there
our mayor was shocked at how handsome I
was in real life they were stunned by my
amazing acting abilities and they were
more marbling in the fact that a guy was
wearing peanut butter on his face it was
almond butter actually so not not that
bad for Ethan because he's allergic and
he would die but almond blood almond
butter I've actually discovered I like
almond butter better than peanut
it's the type that as the skins peeled
off it makes it real
Casey god dammit put the fraggin why
then cure him now we gotta keep going
drink it madhu ski there we go Melinda's
come blue ski and you lose almost there
eventually we're gonna get there someday
someday over the rainbow we're gonna
find a way to get out of here Oh gon go
in the distance let's see
Fonzie that I walk two steps you kidding
me right now I walk two steps I'm not
able to escape because I walk two steps
got real tired from huffing and puffing
down the toes taps quick I was wondering
if by chance you would ever want to play
league of legends with your friends I
feel like it would be pretty fun time I
understand though if not because of
toxicity you know I actually do not like
Liga legends I think those games are not
my type it's not that they're bad like
I'm not saying they're bad or anything
but I personally do not
very much even of remotely a little bit
I I just don't have fun playing and it's
not that that pride everyone is always
assume you don't play it
you must think it's Garbo or you haven't
tried it at the writing no I trust me
I've tried it I've tried it a lot
actually I just I can't find fun in
those types of games I used to but not
only
what I feel the problem is legal
is the repetitiveness it's it I can
understand playing a game for a while
but it's the same thing over and over
again and I know a lot of people would
say but there's so many different
intricacies to it you can climb the
ladder and get better and then you can
win so I mean there's always that carrot
you know to chase after and that's fine
but also at the same time it's like III
get bored of things no you did call no
there's no exit here are you kidding me
all that way you're such an [__]
developer I want to let your game but
you're an [__] this is an [__]
move this is a moving babbles make and
you are very clearly bad oh all right
anyway
now that that's oh boy here we go um
II II
we
Oh evil I don't I'm not good enough to
be able to pronounce Korean just yet but
hey mark always always a funny video
Thanks
I'll always cheer
thank you so much for watching all the
way
Nik mark says I've been watching you
before
got gotten your fame here on YouTube it
may be stupid but have you always wanted
to be your friend
today to be that day well I appreciate
the extension of friendship I'm not I
don't know how to say this in two nights
/ way but I can't be friends with all of
my fans I mean I do appreciate it and
you guys watching me but for me
friendship is keeping up with each other
on a daily basis and even I am not good
at that
I I barely keep up with my friends
isolated type person but thank you so
much for watching and thank you so much
for supporting my channel what I do here
up well we were surprised to barely
bhavanibabu okay Fraser Daisy Oh techno
wing says hey mark me and my girlfriend
Melina need Leo nice Co met in the
comment section of one of your thank-you
videos I owe you so much for letting me
meet my wonderful speaker well
congratulations to you and
congratulations on finding someone in
the comment section of a clanky review
that's actually amazing jcore 17 said
good and Marcus friendly message from
dowel number My partner and I love all
your videos and would love to see
they're hilarious cheers mate from Jared
and Oh Jared and jasmine well thank you
so much the only problem with raft is I
don't know how much I could possibly do
of them poisoning
two of us you dick ah come on I hate
this place I hate this place I hate it
hate it hate this place I hate this
place I hate this place
why is Jack almost dead all right
where's gonna cure that try to heal that
good good gosh this place isn't the
worst goddamn place I've ever seen him
all right better not be a dead end
Mountain Pascoe whose poison when I get
poisoned when did I son of a [__] hi
there we go I'm moving on
scooty Oh Sookie please be yes permits
respites okay oh hi how's it going lord
I know we did
you are support you can't get other and
freely beer when you say oh thank you
but guys the later creep eight-ball
welcome a little creepy all right fine
then exam playing in the rain is fun at
all but now I'm cold
would you like to save not as cold did
you were in the frosty mountain pass I
bet I bet I bet to map this nation steer
him what can I copy it down then maybe I
know where I'm going
no apparently not all right let's see
where this is leading
Oh earthen temple well handy that good
thing good thing they put the temple so
quickly after all that [__] because
if they didn't I would have been
gorgeously pissed like it's staring into
my very soul it's like it's staring into
my dreary so are we ready for this you
know what actually I think I may have to
sleep there because we don't have all of
our NP ready to go so I'm thinking that
we need to sleep at the inn and recover
our debt even though this guy seems a
little bit creepy
oh thank you kindly so
temple at least just party I like how I
blinked and that counted as me sleeping
it's like to me asleep inside
burdensomeness treasure
okay I'm sure it do I'm sure do I'm sure
I'm sure it do so I'm gonna go pokin
with my magic katana stick and then hope
for the best
oh now suddenly I can't run what can I
run in sometimes and not run other times
it's weird and here I was thinking I was
the big one here careful
fly boy here we go again oh man Oh Frick
the poison bats prepare to die
that's a bit of a bit of an egregious
standing to make just come up in there
let's see let's see if Blizzard is gonna
do anything good in this blam uh-huh
blizzard there we go that's what I'm
talking about don't do that okay well
actually that's fine because that didn't
do anything to anybody
you do that one you hit poison a you hit
poison B and you did wizard
[Music]
holy [__] spring water everywhere that
is a that's way too much tip it all
right you finish off that guy you start
hitting Earth and Guardian starting that
guy and then Blizzard one more time that
should finish off the back thank anyone
for maybe not I guess we haven't hit it
all that much oh yes
perfectly time ow well Jack's done well
that's fine we don't read we're not too
worried about that
all rights insane on that one you cure
me you win maybe Oakley blind ah yay
blinded we're actually using stratagems
here which isn't usually the way I go
about these things haha mist douche
nozzle alright there like a heal
everybody move and that would sure be
useful
seems like Batson Berets Bob in st. Kim
silence yeah alright then okay all right
good think Bob's mind is increased to
such incredible level you'll be able to
be his game missed me so let's just
blast at him I'm gonna he'll react we're
gonna blast him up Miami team moving all
right Michelle Kyle says Canadian fans
my family loves your videos the younger
ones don't wash yet but Alex's Gracie
Ross and my husband Sampson all enjoy
your videos I have most of my friends
subscribed so big hugs well thank you so
much for getting the whole Canadian crew
up there subscribed watching I
appreciate that very much and wish them
all the best from me like seriously wish
them all the best
that's awesome as the Android gaming
says hey mark man from my name is Katara
Katara and me and my partner Andrew love
your channel every night we cuddle up
and share laughs to your wonderful
content wonderful content there's been a
lot of adjectives used to describe my
content but I don't know if wonderful
has been at the top
his list is this soap is it still
blinded episode 1 do ha boesky you dead
yet no so blind it ok so this actually
makes it really easy now that we got Bob
on board that's gonna just make
everything wonderful
oh yeah it's fall over fall or not fall
over fall over and up fall over fall
over a guy man come on fall over to fall
over all right um Jan the tiger said
hello mark I've I've uh I follow you
before you hit six million subscribers
and I still see all your weird funny
videos keep up the good work thank you
for helping me through tough times hope
to meet you someday hi from Denmark well
thank you so much I believe you helped
me beat that Guardian Marga by level 13
Elias spark and flame yeah message 15
heal - yes we [__] got a better heal
and then Bob just doesn't matter that's
fine
glammo three dome who knows and I'd love
to go I'd like to think three are down
left to go because there's six rocks and
we got three keys and three rocks have
grown up if I know anything about math
and I don't think I do
oh now what Oh
ah I see
oh great my cute guys again Oh Baba
who's the dumb asses yes and who may
they be hmm
don't think I got over what you did to
his last hit she wouldn't let me forget
with yet
of making Christian sir father
that's what I thought you know this time
we'll stop you
yeah we'll see alright okay then sunny
Chu and Christian again alright I will
see if you're any stronger I don't think
so I'm gonna try flame ah and then we're
gonna try this bad boy and then we're
gonna blind you guys
[Music]
okay so they do take damage from that
but it's technically not as much damage
as if I successful but now that I
blinded like honestly what are they
gonna do to me nothing
nothing a whole lot of nothing spork is
good I like sparks sparks good my
lexpark and then let's just sigh lism
again cuz that's awesome
[Music]
blammo all right
cynical meanness says thank you for
being such an inspiration mark
[Music]
and then Colton Lee operate or says hey
mark I just like to say thank that
you're my inspiration to keep striving
forward in life you always make me and
my family smile I dare to say that
you're my hero thanks for always being
there for us well thank you for always
being there for me because to me that is
infinitely it's the thing that keeps me
going and why do miss miss miss because
you guys suck in our bad Ally majestic
says hey Mark just want to say hi real
quick and hope you guys have a great
time on the tour keep up the great work
in everything that you're doing well
thank you again and I really do
appreciate that how am i pointed when
did I get blinded that's no good at all
is there any way I can cure
Oh recover Oh recover is a heal all I
thought I had that right
I didn't know I had that well I don't
think I can do anything about it now but
hopefully the spells are gonna be just
as effective
maybe we'll see Bram all right ray
Leanne says hey Mark could I get a shout
out for my friend Sabrina please she's
currently in the hospital and has been
for a week now it'll make her super
happy
well shout out to Sabrina hope you
recover in the hospital like I don't
know what's going on but I hope it goes
well for you soon so thank you so much
for watching and are these guys gonna
fall over in diet cheese okay all right
then are they not blind anymore maybe
don't know oh oh that's the opposite of
what I needed right now I wonder if I
can cure that with an item cuz silencing
is just gonna be the death of me if we
have to deal with that item oh I don't
have enough spellers
oh we're just gonna wait it out no all
right then we can do that you guys just
attack let's see uh pastel prick says hi
mark pastel pricks on Instagram he
responds say that you inspire me to keep
drawing we feel like well best of luck
to you in your drawings and good luck on
this trip let's see uh or less you
nexuses greetings from russia mark it's
nice to relax on your livestream after a
hard working day thanks yeah in Russia I
have no idea what time it is over there
in Russia but thanks so much for that
[Music]
all right let's keep going at it the
standard way I guess I mean eventually
if things get dire in terms of health I
will use one of those on yamimash
dimension that he can heal everybody and
hopefully that'll be a little bit better
blam Geist oh my goodness one of these
guys gonna die ok so we need to move I'd
be a waste if I just did a heal there so
I'm gonna have dispel herb on yamimash
you're gonna use a full potion actually
that'll be fun and then you're gonna use
a dispeller because you're just using
useless waiting don't
okay good that was close all right so
this key I mean I know I can just raise
them from K oh so it's not really that
bad
blocked it just because it was in
alright fine then you know that's just
the way it's gonna be you get hit you do
heal - on Jack you do nothing cuz you
can't uh and then you attack it and you
go there
oh I need to blind them again I forgot I
needed to blind them again because
they're no longer flap and if they could
just fall over they got so much health
my god oh geez okay so flap to you heal
to me
I don't know
magic
[Music]
now there we go Elizabeth Williams says
hey mark they were always making me
laugh on a bounty of the truth gift and
it's so amazing that you share also from
one Bearcat to another going you see
love you always
that's the University of Cincinnati
thank you very much Jesse Mayer says a
mark your videos helped me get through
high school and now my live-in boyfriend
knows to put on your videos whenever I
feel sad I love everything you do when I
wish you the best success hello from
Ithaca thank you very much for that and
I wish you the best of success in what
you do now and also you have MS is gonna
kneel himself Jack is going to sit there
like a lump
blimey but at least finally City shoe is
down tastes funny
BLAP uh why do you do double attacks how
do you get stronger how did you get
stronger and why this is shake it
forever alright keep going at it
barreling
see Tori mark please stop using spar
consignee to your healing oh I didn't
realize I was using spark on him I
thought I was using Saint was I oh I
only did that once then I did that once
that was one time I den but good good
call I didn't know that so I'm not gonna
I'm not gonna give you too much [__] for
that but good card I didn't realize that
oops
Carlotta says you are amazing thank you
thank you alright nothing because what
we're supposed to be doing here I don't
think I'm doing any more damage that's
gonna be able to heal him so I think
we're fine there
oh good Jack you're back to us can you
you're still blind so if you miss I'm
not gonna be too happy about it
I'm guessing wins there's nothing I
haven't been paying attention because
the key ah win does nothing okay I've
been I've been dumb about that one
that's my fault
alright so you're just gonna hit him I
guess luckily you can do fire damage
boom
[Music]
fifteen beacons 15 is it because I was
fleeing from all those fights of what
yeah now you're starting to talk and now
I'm starting to beat the crap out of you
no that doesn't do nothing
you know actually let's just have you
spirit bless me because I'm awesome
and you just take damage why don't you
why should loose key Morgan Lars mine
was increased let's see butter cat young
man is 6:38 a.m. why are you awake what
the [__] I don't know where you are but
it is 9:40 please thank you very much
all right you're gonna spirit Blas Bob
and you're gonna keep firing at him
hey Mark just wanted to say if they owe
Eve Sully's are so the hey mark just
wanted to say thanks I suffer from
depression in your videos means so much
to me I'm fun on tour well thank you so
much and I'm glad that my videos could
help out in whatever whatever way they
do you Bob real bad
[Music]
alright if you could just fall over soon
and be great amberlynn said hello mark
and everybody on the stream no no no no
I hope you all are having a great day
night love you all and Mark keeping me
never changed much love it from
I'll try my best but changing is a part
of life and oh ah walls at a magic
anyway so I guess that's fine it's fine
[Music]
fine I guess we just do this this way
then we're just gonna we're just gonna
do the straight-up
mano a mano mano a mano I'm gonna
silence you I'm gonna play what's lucky
what was that all about you douche I
fine attack then just get blinded blind
you ah pockets and black all right
ensue babe says hey mark if you could
send a shout-out to my boys Jack say and
cog e caged her just copy that Kim oh
man I'm an idiot they have been getting
bullied in school your videos help them
smile every
well thank you so much for watching and
I'm sorry getting bullied in school
that should never happen fortunately it
does but just try to stand up to him as
best you can but not through violence
because that doesn't solve anything
okay climate flora tantrum item fire
this is this is going terribly because I
can't do anything oh no can't do that
we're just gonna stand here and be
terrible
no damage it's fine yeah